I'm American I have my own culture when
you go with your people you do what your
cause
Oh Brittany's dad did warn her pay my
90-day fan spam
it's melissa here and just a few i'm
going to give you a quick update on all
of the highlights from the latest
episode of the other way but first we
have to talk about the biggest must-see
moment which goes to brittany enya's on
okay so these two reunite at the airport
it's all sweet at first full of smiles
and roses but they couldn't make it to
the car before use on literally flips
out in Brittany here's why that's just
not good fun
y'all hola
oh poor producer he's just trying to
help if you didn't read the text on the
screen basically as I got mad at
Brittany because she hugged the
producers when she saw them and when she
hugged them she revealed a bottle of
alcohol that was in her bag I am so
stupid I said you cannot to drink here
and you cannot to talk before Babel and
to hug people
sipar who Brittany hints for me oh and
here mr. miacca deed I will Bella do the
advanced reaction was a bit over the top
but to be fair he is feeling a lot of
pressure from his family right now which
is understandable and Brittany didn't
help the situation by telling him not to
worry about the liquor that's in her bag
that's it's not good fun cool during the
episode before Brittany arrived yours on
may all of these promises to his dad he
promised that he was going to try to
convert her to his religion he promised
that she would have her divorce papers
in hand yes his aunts parents think that
Brittany has her divorce papers
yes I'm and his parents don't have a
clue about the status of Brittany's
divorce and how her attorney says that
it's going to take months
his aunts parents are under the
impression that he's gonna marry
Brittany when she lands in Jordan
Sophia's on flipped out over a hug and a
bottle of liquor I'm just I'm worried
I'm concerned on how he's gonna react
when he finds out that Brittany is still
married seeing this behavior makes me
second-guess moving here it reminded me
of the way my ex behaves and so if he's
gonna behave like my ex then I don't
want anything I do with him we're just
going to have to wait and see how all of
this pans out yeah it's a lot but in the
meantime let's talk about our mando who
finally built the courage to talk to his
parents about his sexuality and Kenneth
and I must say I was so excited to see
that things turned out way better than
expected
[Music]
this hog is something I've been wanting
for a very long time
our final highlight of the episode goes
to Ginny and sumit who move into their
new place in India and some it admits
that it's not the safest so this house
is cheaper than our apartment that we
were living in anger doll right it's no
cheaper that because little abandoned
from the main city that's why I see when
I cannot afford much we need to be like
more alert and moping like careful here
crime ratio was very high over here at
least you're there that's what matters
next week on the other way Binyam makes
his debut we finally get to meet Tim in
May Lisa and we get to see the aftermath
of Brittany and you zines big fight
alright my 90-day fan spam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all see you next time
[Music]